t'as du courrier mon père est mort quand
son père est mort carole perceval je
vous présente caroline laugier votre
demi soeur et trésor je voulais juste
vous demander pardon non pas avoir été à
vos côtés chagan qu'ils soient morts
j'aurais tellement aimé lui [ __ ] en
prend dans la gueule et karité
votre père a tenu à vous laisser un
chalet sur les hauteurs de courchevel
niche dans fin fond du trou du cul du
monde sait ça non mais quel gros que moi
tu vas arrêter de tirer la gueule à
chaque fois que dit que c'est un gros
coin est pas mort je prépare un casse
et ça c'est le stradivarius que j'ai
volé à san sebastian à 13,6 et un violon
fabriqué aux alentours de 700 car je
sais ce que c'est merci wiki [ __ ] à
mon avis ça frôle et du bio
je pensais plutôt à 15 qui la règle d'or
c'est prévisions préparation précision
les cultiver ses moyens tant que tu
adores forêt pour qui j'étais presque ah
bon ces deux là où j'ai test va super
brillant
ils étaient 100 tables
non mais l'enfoiré nous ment depuis le
début je suis vraiment allé je suis
votre père
sans d'ailleurs on se relâche et là
que le code de la manette